in the West African country of Benin
where voodoo was born it is an official
religion practiced by more than four
million believers Voodoo's exact origins
are elusive but it is said to have
evolved out of the region's traditions
of ancestor worship and animism aza good
news is a third generation voodoo priest
and he'll he treats patients and
presides over rituals in a shrine of the
earth spirit mechana horny aza sees the
benefits of hoodoo everywhere yes people
are sick and we hope they are cured if
some people don't have enough money we
improve who do so they will get money in
mind over long in the local language
thawne voodoo means spirit while
practitioners believe in only one true
God they communicate with him through
thousands of different spirits and
shrines
even for a priest it can be dangerous to
disobey a spirits wishes years ago a
spirit demanded that Oz's daughter Hasib
ax become a medium a vessel for the
deity but aza wanted his daughter to get
a modern education at first he disobeyed
the spirits commands but over time
aza realized the Spirit was flirting his
plan for his daughter has a lot like it
she didn't understand why the teacher
was saying luego Delia and she couldn't
hear when the teacher spoke very great
anything on Thea what sort of the
article and learn that if she did not
become a votive questioner then she
would never find a good path in life for
his daughter to achieve her potential
aza has to let her become a medium this
forest harbors the earth spirit sack
betta
here is whereas IBAs journey begins it
was a grandfather's worshipper do and
what not to us now our daughter wants to
Russian you do confirm God and leave the
rest up to you suddenly the spirit
claims a Sivas body overcoming her these
people believe the spirit has actually
killed a senior now in the grip of
spirits of the Dead the girl's body
received gentle care given with the hope
that in time the earth spirit will
return alive
osebo will lie here for three days
without food or water
aza hopes to see a Seba reborn but he
knows her fate is up to the spirit three
days later the spirits of the Dead still
control a Sivas body her father
aza hopes they are about to give his
daughter back
me what your day the course
Lumiere mr. Lentz I'll perf along now we
want to go and prepare from here in
front of the community a spray of
cornmeal rids the path of evil to signal
passage from the world of the Dead to
the world of the Spirit the body must
come feet first into the village open
palms invoke the spirit inviting it to
return in voodoo contact with a chicken
purifies the body preparing it for birth
still a Seba seems lifeless a priestess
calls on the spirits to release their
hold on her body
finally a muted cry this display of
spirit power overwhelms worshipers a
series of ceremonies purifies a Simba's
physical self with his daughter revived
and reborn aza feels enormous relief now
that my daughter is resurrected I can
relax the end of my body is revived from
the world of the dead and now the spirit
isn't happy I am very happy
my daughter's following us is just
tradition a Seba still need years of
training but in time she will take her
place as a spirit medium